before i moved here i've never
used a chainsaw
[Music]
i couldn't even lift them all for
splitting rounds
this is the spot yeah there's one right
up here
that i had picked out for you there's a
lot of cedars up in there
tree fallen's a very dangerous dangerous
occupation
you got to remember that saw is not your
friend that's not going to watch out for
you
all i can think of is that trees coming
down on me
it wants to go the other way it's
starting to move keep going mary don't
stop
that tree can bite you back in a
heartbeat not fast
cut fast keep going you might not live
to tell the story
don't stop come on come on
i am not ready for winter at all
things go in threes and we had three
easy winners so i think this year we're
gonna get slammed
for the people of southeast alaska the
keys to their future
often lie in the lessons of their
pioneering past
for seven year resident mary miller
surviving the long alaskan winter
requires planning for the future
today this means stocking up on firewood
i'm not comfortable with what i have
here it's definitely not gonna get me
through the winter
together a sufficient supply requires
mary to add a fundamental
but particularly risky skill to her
arsenal of talents
i purchased a new chainsaw this summer
but i've actually never cut a tree down
and i want to be able to do it myself
rather than have to barter with someone
to get me my wood i want to be more
self-sufficient
but it's very dangerous falling trees
i got to learn how to read the trees in
which way they're going to fall
so i've naturally picked curly he is the
man when it comes to
falling trees and stuff known as the
woodsman
18-year resident and third generation
lager timothy curley leach
has been behind the saw for 30 years
mary she ain't afraid to get her hands
dirty i mean she scared a bear she had
scared a
wolf she ain't scared of the sasquatch
for crying out loud
whoa you scared me hey mary
sorry didn't mean to scare you that's
not true
that looks like your yellow cedar pile's
getting down there
it is i bet burning fast as i can
chip it yeah right right right now
people are
collecting their firewood and that
they're pretty hot and heavy so
i'm going to take mary with me and give
her some pointers and
steer her in the right direction that's
a cute little saw
so that's a step up from the barbie saw
i was using
you don't need anything bigger than that
anyway i've just cut
these rounds on the beach with it is all
i've done
i'm a little leery you know you read the
box and it says all the do's and don'ts
and the chain
kicking back at you and the bar and
stuff very frightening maybe i watch
too many scary b movies with chainsaws
but i want to
load up in fact mary's anxieties are
well-founded
as professions go none is deadlier than
logging
there's snow in the forecast in the next
couple days so
this is my chance to get out there
i need to go out there and learn these
skills and get it right and do it now
otherwise it's going to be a long
cold winter
nature's the most powerful force out
here we have
if we don't maintain our trails mother
nature will overtake it
and you'll never find it again
i hate this one right here this will be
so nice to get this fixed
high on the hill behind their property
11-year residents hans and timby porter
are fortunate enough to have a massive
supply of firewood
they call the blowdown there we go
but keeping this reserve accessible all
year round will require substantial
overhauls their trail
and every time we go up there our trail
just keeps getting worse and worse
so we're gonna try and fix that today
this is ridiculous oh my gosh hans
you made it the things i do for you
thank you baby being able to get up to
the blowdown
is like supremely important
your access back and forth to your wood
supply needs to be
safe when you run out of firewood it's
serious
[Music]
what i'm thinking is we can take the
ends that i've cut off
and then put them in the mud hole and
set part of that beam right up on top of
it
use it for a bridge i think that's
pretty damn smart
for some of us out here in port
protection who are
getting a little bit older seems like
our chores are getting a little bit more
and more difficult
is there a bottom to that anytime you
have to
go through shin deep muck to
get to the job site it just kind of
takes a toll on you
may seem like a trail to you but uh
for us it's survival and that turned out
pretty well lucky
260 pounds
[Laughter]
[Music]
alaskan tested wife approved
the stairway to the mountaintop next
what do you think i don't know this is
going to be
a project having only put a dent into
their battle with mother nature
the porters have yet to tackle the
steepest section of their firewood trail
the lengthy incline to the blowdown this
is where it's bad i know
every step man you never know if the
ground's just gonna give way on you and
you're gonna slip in that
stuff in the temperate rain forest the
forest floor is largely composed of
thick mosses
carpeting centuries of decomposing
deadfall resulting in
soggy uneven and often treacherous
terrain
you know what maybe we can get some
steps put in here
it looks like we're gonna have a hell of
a run of steps though huh
well it's all uphill from here on out
over the years i've learned that you got
to take care of yourself
the winter season always makes
everything harder no matter what it is
since port protection's beginning the
staple red meat has always been
venison i'm a little bit behind on my
hunting this year
and a doe there could be crucial i'll
tell you it's a lot of work to make it
through the winter
having had no success at two hunts
earlier this season
seventy-year-old gary mulberger is
changing tack in his final effort to bag
a deer
before the snow falls
well it froze pretty hard last night it
looks like winter's here
the backpack's frozen the weather might
put kind of a kibosh to me here it
froze really hard last night and so i'm
going to have to maybe go in the timber
there the
muskegs are going to be froze and
everywhere i walk is going to be
crunching i'm just going to be telling
them that i'm coming
so i have to get a different approach to
this and i'm just going to have to look
and play it by ear
gary puts 2.5 nautical miles between
himself and civilization
in order to better his chances of a
successful deer hunt
you can't go today dropper sorry
most of the deer are shot off that show
their face on the road system there
those are thinned out they're gone
you have to get where they can't be seen
from the road you have to hunt those
places out
getting older now and those miles are a
little harder for me
i got a four-wheeler there sometimes i
called a scooter
the unique thing about the four-wheeler
is that i can get up and
off of the road where i can't go with
the truck
opens up new country to me the
four-wheeler some places can drive right
up to the deer
i can winch it up throw it on there and
i don't have to work as hard to get it
well here we go
[Music]
there's a lot of competition on the road
there's a lot of young guys there
they cover the ground pretty good so i
got to get off the beaten path
to see where there is a deer
oh it doesn't matter here it feels like
maybe the belt's slipping or something
when you're gonna do what i got in mind
here there's a few tools that you need
but it's just like a lot of stuff they
don't make them like they used to and
you can't rely on them all the time
oh something's a matter here
oh god miles from port protection
a malfunction in gary mulberg's atv
threatens to end his late season deer
hunt
before it's even begun you can feel
something that feels like maybe the
belt's slipping or something the motor
turns up and don't go nowhere
i'm thinking the oil from the crank
cases
going into that other chamber
sure enough the oil's down
so somehow the engine oil is going
into the chamber where the belt is and
so the belt is slipping
i know for a fact that this isn't
something i'm going to fix right here or
on the road here
i'm just going to have to come up with
another plan
i guess i'll just go back to old school
get my rifle and go
put five or ten miles on the whole feet
that's the way i used to do it hit the
brush
finding my way here in port protection
has been a little bit of a challenge
everybody here has been so helpful and i
am extremely
thankful it's made life quite a bit
easier here
but i wouldn't have stayed if i didn't
have
the determination to with the owner soon
returning to her cabin
three-year resident amanda mccarr has
only three days to move into her
houseboat
the why not and make it her permanent
home and port protection
i'm gonna freeze my ass off but in order
to stay warm during the cold nights in
the water
amanda's best bet for survival is an
old-fashioned heat source
the white knot has one diesel stove on
it but
i gotta make room for a wood stove
because my diesel stove isn't working
[Music]
try and get some of this stuff out of
the way
probably one of the most important
things to figure out in the wintertime
keeping yourself warm without heat
you'll die
oh another reason why you should
oil up your rusty fasteners
i just busted the tip of my screwdriver
sucky i've called on my friend sam
carlson
to come over and help me plan out and
install a wood stove
i would say you have your work cut out
for you
and the sky is blue and the grass is
green yeah
when i stepped on board amanda's
houseboat uh
it kind of brought back some memories
because i i spent a winter in one when i
was in junior high
and i just remembered how cold it was
wow yeah you're gonna need some heat and
once you have heat you'll
have a totally different attitude change
that'll be nice
you're gonna want at least 12 inches
from your wall just for fire protection
purposes
my biggest worry with this project is
possibly burning the boat down fiber or
glass is highly flammable
and i'm going to put a fire source
inside
the boat one of the inherent dangers in
actually having a wood stove anywhere
you definitely have to have adequate
fire protection
but the main thing is safety safety
first boats are kind of like trailer
houses
confined spaces you have to have a
little extra fire protection
[Music]
i do have faith in sam and his
capabilities
i attempted it earlier but i broke my
tip
trying to get this oops i thought maybe
i could just pull it out
it felt like it would just come right
out i don't know what it's attached to
the wall but when you have people
coming over and just tearing pieces off
of your home
it can be rather concerning this is
going to get covered with drywall so
you're not going to see any of this
[Music]
job done handle removed
that's a wee bit of a challenge i've
never actually installed stove
a wood stove in a boat hopefully we will
be successful
[Music]
tree falls very dangerous dangerous
occupation
that tree can bite you back in a
heartbeat and you might not live to tell
the story
this is the spot yeah there's one right
up here that i
had picked out for you there's a lot of
cedars up in there
2.5 nautical miles east of poor
protection
seasoned logger timothy curly leach has
brought seven-year resident mary miller
out in the road
to teach her how to chop down a dead
standing tree
i think i could handle it i will give it
her a shot
i carry my soil like curly and look cool
now before i moved here i've never
used a chainsaw i couldn't even lift
them all for splitting rounds but now i
could swing it all day long and split
that wood up
yikes nice easy one though
yeah easy for you to say you know what
the hell you're doing
you just acclimate to what you need to
do to survive out here oh
i don't know this is scary girlie i
can't
help it yeah i think she's pretty
nervous about it she's a little gun shy
of chainsaws which is a good thing
i'm just gonna go ah i already know they
say if you're not
scared you know you ain't got no
business cutting trees
when operating a chainsaw you got to
remember that saw's not your friend
that's not going to watch out for you
you're going to cut flat into it like
that good lord
okay chopping down a tree is dangerous
business
as she works mary must keep an eye out
for falling limbs
kick back from her saw and last but not
least
the tree itself falling in her direction
boy i don't know
curly if i feel safe i'm gonna get a
lean over there going downhill
with a chainsaw running yeah right you
can do it
you're all right
smells flooded i smell gas smell gas
yeah
it needs you
boy i don't like it
i'll coach you through it though go
ahead
[Music]
look down your handlebars now get down
and just let the saw go
it's kind of different watching somebody
else cutting a tree usually i'm on the
end of the song
you want that pointed right to the left
of them although
okay you're all right you're doing just
fine
it's all free all i can think of is that
trees coming down on me i'm gonna roll
down the hill you know all these things
that could happen
there you go try that
i don't know about this stuff mary
you gotta have your saw flat
as of right now i'm scared to death of
the thing
oh god crew you're fine you're doing
just fine
let me get back over here and i'll kind
of watch korea wants to go the other way
it's starting to move you're fine don't
panic
just go ahead
keep going mary don't stop
got fast keep going don't stop
[Music]
wants to go the other way and starting
to move don't
it just go ahead and cut out in the
alaskan wilderness
first time logger mary miller confronts
her first dead standing tree
an intimidating 90-foot yellow cedar
keep going mary don't stop
[Music]
get over here
[Music]
see you did
it i did it
you did got an adrenaline rush going
god i bet my heart is pounding
[Laughter]
when the tree finally came down it was
so many different emotions going through
my head i mean it's like
relief it's down you know you're told me
to cut fast and the drops were coming
down
from the tree it hit me it's like oh
this
[Laughter]
you froze in your tracks the expression
on her face was pretty priceless you
know first time even really running a
saw period you know and to jump into
cutting a tree she did a good job you
know i was pretty proud of her
good lord that's more of a rush than
dropping a deer let me tell you
everything worked out okay everyone was
safe
but now the hard part starts where i saw
them up
split them and get it stacked
what makes a place like port protection
really work is that we
end up helping each other more than
we're really aware of because it kind of
becomes second nature
in order to reach their firewood supply
hans and timmy porter are forced time
and again
to climb a muddy slippery trail to the
top of a mountain
i think these steps are gonna be kind of
involved don't you
well i've always found that steps are
always an uphill battle
making the soggy rain forest floor
accessible sometimes requires experience
and tools born of decades surviving the
alaskan bush
hey you me made it better late than
never
living out here we try to use all the
resources that we can at our disposal
and one of the greatest resources i know
is but
look what you brought now we just got to
do stairs
i've been helping bud get wood for the
last couple years
so i invited him to come up and help us
so we can keep the wood flowing
straight up and down almost slippery
right up and down gosh i can't even stay
up well we just put in an escalator
yeah right oh we got lots of stuff to
work with
i think that there is so much valuable
information that the people
in this village have finding out the
little tricks and tips from people like
bud
it's huge to us this is your furrow
yeah and do you make that yes that's
pretty awesome
branch and uh rubber tires rubber
compresses and it
fires it down into the wood but brought
up a
shake fro and a mallet and these are
some old-timey tools
and we'll do it the old-fashioned way
bud's lightweight tools however
unassuming have been essential to
centuries of construction
okay ready yep the team makes the steps
by placing the froze blade against the
log and hitting it with a mallet
creating precisely measured shake boards
without the cumbersome aid of the modern
mill
[Music]
oh i know that's right that's
mine well we haven't done for today
the thing about making boards the mallet
that you use
is going to break it's just a matter of
when i ain't got nothing to swat it with
bro
i'm sorry about breaking your mallet but
i can build genuine
wait and let's go do it all right let's
do it
how to stand still till we get a new one
okay out here it's the little things
that throw you off
but it's always something
the best laid plans of mice and men they
can change
but you can't dwell on that you gotta
roll with it
and just say to yourself well you're
just gonna have to do it the hard way
after running into a belt issue with his
atv
seventy-year-old gary mulberger pushes
deep into the alaskan bush
to continue his doe hunt the
old-fashioned way alone
and on foot well you can see there's
been deer all over here
there's trucks all over
even at my age i rely on my legs and
hips and my body to take me where i want
to go
and so that's how i'm going to hunt
one of the things about hunting on foot
you can go old places
where even the atv can't go
there's another deer bed right here
well there's deer right there they're
living here
little luck i can sneak up on one
well he rubbed it out of this right here
there's a deer you see it
this is dope
there's deer all over in this country
here
well he rubbed it out of this right here
four miles into his trek hunter gary
mulberger has found himself in a closed
logging road
abundant with deer sign there's a deer
you see it this is dope
there she goes
now what was standing right there i had
a you know dead shot but
you can see you can't get here with a
four-wheeler
it's hell for me pack one out of here
i mean but anyway that's
give me a little charge and we'll go up
this way
there was one here i say there's more
try this one more time
[Music]
it's pretty hard living out here
back in business nice you guys
i found that it's a lot easier to get
things accomplished when you work
together
with a new mallet assembled the porters
and neighbor bud baker
finish constructing shake boards and
stakes using old-fashioned tools
and the natural resources around them
six seven
eight of them now all that's left is to
construct the stairs
and pray they'll hold
wow those are heavy must be hemlock
yeah ain't going nowhere it'll be there
for a while
for bud to stop up and help us this
neighbor helping neighbor helping
neighbor that makes this community work
it seems like a lot of people pay it
forward those are some nice looking
boards
they are nice looking boards it's coming
along
so well
we're working together to achieve
something that's going to benefit us and
we try to do it with
love and compassion for each other
that's really what it's all about
for us you get a project go to work have
a good time get her done
call it a day just about right
yeah another one just about right but
well these are some nice steps look at
this you guys this is
huge we won't be mud up to her neck
or anything else or anything else
this is so cool hey there's holes out
there you could lose a small kid in
[Music]
if you really want a taste of personal
freedom
and just all around self-sufficiency
nothing quite like owning your own home
at this stage of the game for amanda in
her life it's definitely going to be a
struggle to you know get things whipped
into shape
but that builds character
with days remaining before her move
amanda mccarr
and her friend sam carlson are
scrambling to build a wood-burning stove
to help heat the 33-year-old's new
houseboat
during the winter chill the wai-na is my
very first
residence so it's pretty important to me
to make sure that all these projects are
done properly
while amanda fire proofs the walls of
her house boat sam constructs the wood
stove out of salvage materials
amanda she knows that i have skills with
making things
from scrap and it's always good to be
able to share that knowledge
i lived on my boat when i was 16 and a
half
i had lots of help there's no way in
hell i could claim that i didn't have
lots of help
but there were enough old timers around
crestfuel farts that were more than
willing to
just tell you this is how you do it
time to cut some sheet rock 25
and three quarters i feel pretty
intimidated
by my wood stove i don't want to catch
anything on fire
burn somebody else's house down or put
anybody else's lives in jeopardy
what this does is it creates a gap
between the wall
and the sheet rock so that things have a
chance to
keep cool ta-da so nothing catches on
fire
let's say it's about factory perfect
always nice when the plan comes together
take this over to amanda's and hopefully
she'll have a hot boat by tomorrow
ahoy special delivery
and there you go got it got it looks
great sam
all right yeah that looks great i hired
the right man for the job
and i'd like to see that at least that
far from
this wall uh-huh
see we're off
special delivery and there you go
got it got it looks great sam
with the new wood stove assembled sam
returns to amanda's houseboat to
complete the installation
i'd like to see that at least that far
from
this wall but he discovers a glaring
issue
see we're off we can't use this as the
middle
still pipe's actually going to be over
here having failed to take into account
the placement of the ceiling joist
sam and amanda will now have to shift
the stove's installation one foot to the
right
i don't generally drop plans or
schematics i just have this thing in my
head
generally there's always modifications
on the fly while you're doing the job so
i just hope there's no big stumbling
block
good i hope this works
i can't believe we're cutting a hole in
my perfectly fine room
[Music]
i hear amanda down below going i cannot
believe
somebody is cutting a hole in the roof
of the boat uh you go go ahead and push
on it
there you go sorry that didn't get me
it's like
there's been a trend in alaska people
moving out of the bush and then you know
back into the cities
and it's nice to see young people that
are hanging in there tough
learning how to do everything right i
think
that you're good okay yeah i think
you're good that's fine i
came to port protection because of a boy
that relationship did not work out and
i decided to stay this place has
captivated me so
there are so many things that keep me
here the energy
the people the lifestyle and i can't see
wanting to leave it anytime soon
i think it's time to christen the stove
pipe
i've hunted deer for two weeks at a time
without getting one
coming home empty-handed
hunter gary mulberger has hiked four
miles into the alaskan bush
down closed off logging roads in hopes
of finally bagging a deer
for his winter store all you got to do
is just make a little bit of noise and
then deer will obey you they circle
around behind you and
you never see them again so winter isn't
what gets you
it's not being prepared for winter
that's what will get you
i need a certain amount if i don't catch
one today
this is my last chance for this year
i just kind of have a little feeling for
where i am and
different direction i i'm switching
directions all the time but i'm just
going by the deer trail
i don't know how many more years i'll be
able to do this but i can give the young
guys a little run for their money just
because of experience
[Music]
they make it tough don't they
and there's deer all over in this
country here
this is fresh it ain't frozen
well there's deer here there's all kind
of sign there they're rubbing all over
here
this is as good a spot as any may be
better than some
you just have to keep keep trying
eventually one will make a mistake and
hopefully i won't
they're living here so
something's ahead of us right here
it's pretty brushy but there's still a
few open spots
did you see it
she's running
it's pretty brushy but there's still a
few open spots
did you see it after three hours
traveling on foot
70 year old gary mulberger finally has a
deer in his sights
she's running
i'm gonna put her down now
she's dead big doe
wasn't a good shot went down
this is what i wanted this is my
christmas present right here so
thank you lord for this deer
[Music]
the old way is the good way for me i'm
at pretty good physical condition
because i walk a lot in what i eat
i was really surprised i could still run
[Music]
you want to dispatch these stairs quick
as possible
the blood is the first thing to spoil
and once you get the bacteria going then
you don't have too long
if you can get them blood out good
you'll have some meat that'll last
longer i gotta get moving here it's
getting darker and
i got a ways to walk here before i'd be
back to transportation
when you get out in the woods they're
off the road
way out there you gotta figure out what
you're gonna do once you get it there
yeah boy i wish i had that four-wheeler
right now because
i could just put it on the back and it'd
be all done
but it's broke down as it is i gotta
make a pack out of this thing and
be the mule here good thing my name is
mule burger
[Music]
in the old days my brother taught me how
to make a backpack out of this deer
by toggling the front legs i got a these
legs skinned out
to make a toggle out of them so you take
it like this
you put your foot through there
pull it on through and then there's your
toggle that holds that one
you take the other one
shove the foot through toggle it over
well now you know why i wear a red coat
because this one's going to turn red
pretty quick it's not the easiest
thing to do but since i didn't have my
four-wheeler or my truck
that's what i'm going to do is pack it
on my back the old-school way
i kind of proved something to myself
today i haven't done this for a long
time
i can shoot a deer put it on my back go
through the woods bring it back home
i'm 70 years old and i still could put
that deer on my back and
and pack it
i look in the mirror and there's this
old guy there but
i don't see me there i'm still a young
guy
[Music]
there's a lot of things that we do out
here to survive and make our lives more
comfortable
a lot of it's very dangerous and you get
yourself in some
pretty scary predicament but you gotta
learn
because that's the only way you're gonna
not be relying on other people
on the road curly and mary returned to
the tree they fell
the day before why is it gonna be so
cold it makes everything twice as
exhausting
yeah the forecast calls for the snow to
be falling pretty heavy here
coming up this whole next week so it's
really important to get some
good hot burning wood me toes is froze
okay you'll want to flip that over mary
there you go you got it now it's already
curly half of you having to babysit
well that's all right hell you gotta
learn
when teaching mary how to do this i kind
of feel a little bit responsible you
know taking her under my wing and that
you know just pick up some general
pointers that are going to keep her safe
out there
well here we go okay let's do it
good he's making us look so easy curly
someday i will be that good i'm fairly
lucky to have friends like curly
it's just huge that people that have
been here how much
they can help you in your day-to-day
life man this thing weighs a ton
beautiful the number one thing is it'll
probably give her more confidence in
herself about going out
actually doing it on her own
perfect okay now do i go
this way or get it in the cat first
before you
gas it up throttle up
i'll always be afraid of the saw and
respect it
very dangerous tool and you must have a
lot of respect for it and know how to
use it or
don't be messing around with it
[Music]
i'm glad that curly took the time out to
take me out to do that because i feel a
lot more comfortable with that saw now
by the end of the day i was you know
had a lot more confidence and it's just
one more step
and be able to conquer all these fears
and do these things myself
i can see mary going out and i can see
her really getting into this tree fall
and stuff you know i
i think she'll be really good at it and
pretty soon she'll be having all kinds
of fun you won't be able to take her saw
away from her
there is an end in sight for break
making work today
yeah a good day all at all
ah i'm whooped
port protection endures not by modern
advances
but by those who look to the past to
preserve their future
watch this cool knot to start it off
with you ready sometimes it's better to
go with old school technology
we can learn a lot from our old-timers
that's how we've learned a lot ourselves
by other people's experiences if i can
tie a knot and win your heart
it's been a good day there is faith
in time-honored methods a determination
to keep a rich history alive
the old-timers those are the guys that
they're known here
and they continually come home with the
deer
they don't whine about it they'll go
there and hunt until they get what they
need and
that's just how it is it's a boy
each individual has a respect for those
who came before
and an eagerness to forge a clear path
for those who will someday take their
place
super sweet sam it's nice to know that
we still have that pioneering spirit
because once we lose that it's game over
i think that
the world would become a very stale
place if there weren't pioneers
this is port protection
[Music]
you